so let's get more reaction now to the
events here in Downing Street in the
last 24 hours joining me now is the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves a very
good morning to you Rachel Reeves thanks
so much for good morning good morning
what do you make of the resignation of
the Prime Minister do you welcome Liz
trust standing there
the longer the conservatives are in
power the less fit they are for
government to govern they can't just
pass around being prime minister and
being Chancellor like it's as some sort
of game of past the parcel they've done
huge damage now to our economy to our
Global standing in the wild and it's
time for a general election to choose a
government who can provide the stability
and the leadership that the country
desperately needs
well yes you want a general election but
it's not going to happen is it I mean
that's in the gift of the Prime Minister
and anyone who takes over from Liz truss
isn't going to call one
well look I know that there are a lot of
decent conservative MPS so we're also
incredibly worried about the state of
the country the volatility and financial
markets the damage that that is all
doing to the finances of families and
pensioners right across the country and
I would urge them to do the right thing
and get the general election that we
need because I'm afraid at just a
changing the person at the top changing
the person at number 10 and number 11 is
not going to undo all of the damage that
the conservatives have done not just in
the last 45 days but frankly in the last
12 years where we've got economic growth
on the floor interest rates and
inflation uh extraordinary levels and
this is a crisis clearly made in Downing
Street but it is increasingly working
people and some of the most vulnerable
in society who are paying the price for
that
so what will you do to try to secure a
general election will you push for a
confidence vote in the new prime
minister
well we're looking at all different uh
opportunities but in the end as as you
suggested earlier Anna we would have to
work with conservative MPS to be able to
do that because uh despite everything
they do have a majority in the House of
Commons but I know that there are a lot
of conservative MPS who share the
worries of their constituents that
another conservative prime minister and
Chancellor aren't going to be able to
sort out this mess the government has no
mandate from the British people for what
they're doing at the moment and no
mandate for a new prime minister and a
new Chancellor and that is why it is so
important to restore the stability that
we need in our country our ability to
pay our way in the world to get a grip
of the inflation and the interest rate
pressures that are out there at the
moment to secure family finances that we
cannot carry on like this and the only
way to resolve the big challenges that
we have is to have a government with a
mandate to provide the stability and the
leadership that people are crying out
for right now and are not going to get
under the conservatives
well if you're relying on Tory MPS it's
very unlikely you'll manage to secure
that general election and some might say
that at two years will give the labor
party a chance to really familiarize the
public with what they what they stand
for what their policies are or are you
worried that you'll lose popularity over
the next two years before a general
election
my biggest concern right now Anna is
what is happening in the country
um people who are coming off fixed rate
mortgage deals 1.8 million of them by
the end of next year are looking to pay
an extra 580 pounds a month on average
well yes in higher mortgage payments
alone so that is why I'm saying that we
need a general election
um you know as long as it takes labor
will continue to put the case to people
but the sooner that we can have an
election the sooner that the country can
get the stability and Leadership yes
well sorry to interrupt you but you're
right we are in the middle of a cost of
living crisis and some people will say
that's exactly why we don't need the
uncertainty of a general election
campaign
well you know I would just say that the
volatility that we've seen in the
financial markets has put increased
pressure on government borrowing but
it's also put increased borrowing costs
on families and businesses and and
everybody else I've been in Cardiff for
the last um uh 24 hours talking
particularly to small businesses here
about their fears for the future but
with people at not having the money to
uh to go to the shops uh the increased
energy costs that businesses are facing
people are worried sick about the future
worried sick about the cost of living
and they fear that just a new
combination of conservative prime
minister and Chancellor you know the
third conservative prime minister in a
year we're already on the fourth
conservative Chancellor in just four
months this is unprecedented and the
Damage every single day that the
conservatives are doing both to family
finances but also to our Global standing
in the world it is incredibly depressing
and it is taking a toll on people's
lives and people's livelihoods the
conservatives can't just swap around
who's in charge and they can't treat
number 10 and number 11 Downing Street
like it's some sort of short stay Airbnb
it's far too important for that and we
need a government with a mandate a
mandate from the British people to make
some of the difficult decisions that are
needed but to provide the leadership the
certainty and the stability that our
country needs well yes you talk about
difficult decisions I mean realistically
labor would have to spend the next two
years raising taxes and cutting spending
as well wouldn't they
well the reason we are talking about
these difficult decisions is because of
the damage that the conservatives have
done a month ago nobody was
contemplating the need for spending uh
reductions that is uh only on the agenda
now because of the spike in borrowing
costs brought about by the incredibly
irresponsible decisions of the
conservative party
um over the last few weeks but also so
that the labor would have to deliver the
last 12.
sorry Rachel well we've already do
accept then that labor would have to go
ahead with spending cuts and tax Rises
well the first thing that I would say to
that is nobody knows because we do not
have an independent forecast from the
office for Budget responsibility and
we're in the extraordinary situation of
going into a conservative leadership
contest the second this year and also
going into potential uh fiscal statement
from the latest Chancellor in just over
a week's time with nobody knowing the
true scale of the damage that has been
done to our public finances that's why
in the House of Commons two days ago
labor called for the government to
publish the latest forecasts for the
office for Budget responsibility we know
that the government have had those
forecasts since uh Liz trust became a
prime minister uh 45 or 46 days ago we
deserve to see those so that we can
understand the true state of the public
finances because at the moment and
nobody knows there's full extent of the
damage and so it's very difficult to put
forward fully funded and fully costed
plans when we do not know the damage
that has been done
any thoughts on which candidate you'd
like to win
yesterday
the person who can provide the stability
that the country needs you know the
conservatives can carry on with their
past the parcel game but the country
deserves an awful lot better than that
we deserve a general election and the
chance for the people to choose who the
government is
not what I meant but I I guess that was
always the way you would answer the
question Rachel Ruiz thanks very much
and do for your time this morning